[Music]
it is
seven o'clock here in the uk good to see
you this morning
our top story reckless or right
the prime minister has laid out his
plans for easing covert restriction in
england but there is something of a
backlash this morning
over issues including face masks we'll
be speaking to the health secretary
sergeant javid in just a few minutes
time the shadow health secretary
jonathan ashworth
and a former chief scientific advisor
also on the show
uh we'll also be discussing uh this the
latest
from the england campus players train
ahead of tomorrow's semi-final
plus i'll be speaking to one of gareth
southgate's former players
this is also on the show this room is
the council chamber this is one of the
coolest rooms in my house because this
is the room where in 1608
guy fawkes was interrogated over the
gunpowder plot
yep we'll be speaking to the comedian
who lives
lives in the tower of london it is
tuesday the 6th of july
unmasked people politicians and
scientists express fears
over plans to fully unlock england with
concerns over making face coverings
a personal choice we're not wearing it
yeah i won't be wearing mine we need to
learn how to manage but i don't think we
should be so ridiculous as to stop
wearing masks
bursting the bubble could the mass
isolation of school classes be ending
soon
key targets missed and too few staff the
calls
for urgent action in england's maternity
services that could save
a thousand babies a year
ready for the fight as coalition forces
head for the exit in afghanistan
we speak to those trying to stop the
taliban regaining control
and did somebody say it was july the
weather forecast not particularly
summary
all the details coming up a little bit
later in the programme
come on do it
[Music]
hope you've had your breakfast uh the
greatest guinea of all hollywood stars
paid tribute to the director richard
donner
who's died aged 91
[Music]
morning all reckless and divisive
are just the right thing to do there is
a bit of a backlash this morning over
the prime minister's plans to ease
covert restrictions
on july the 19th so-called freedom day
well we've been speaking to people
politicians and scientists who are
concerned about the pace of the
unlocking
with delta cases on the rise there are
questions too over
exactly when people should choose to
wear those face masks
and whether or not that should include
public transport at the health secretary
sajid javid will be on the show shortly
but first
let's take you through the plans
outlined by the prime minister
at first there will be no limits on
social contact so groups of
any size can meet the legal requirement
to where face masks will be removed
instead
people will be expected to use their own
judgment their common sense
all remaining businesses including
nightclubs well they will be allowed to
reopen
people will also not be required
to work from home covert passports
remember them well they won't be needed
for entry into events
helen smith reports now on the mixed
emotions
to yesterday's announcement from clubs
and crowds
to masks and mandates restrictions have
ruled for so long
but when is the right time to reverse
them
in leeds student district relief was on
order
a more normal uni nightlife now beckons
for these friends and twin brothers
there's lost time to make up i've spent
the entire year
at home i've studied at home i've not
left the house and if they've got
football stadiums of
sixty thousand people in my car and i
dance
harder tonight for you open them up man
why not um
it's been a while i think everyone's
pretty much vaccinated now so yeah back
on
but caution's common too and it will
take more than just rules changing to
bring office districts like this
back to life mike's consultancy was once
based near here
but he's let the space go his staff work
from home
the world's changed he says and the
virus still with us
the people who work for us have seen
positive benefits in terms of
money in their pocket because they're
not paying to commute as a business
owner we've seen a positive business
benefiting costs because we're not
paying for an office
so would you feel comfortable bringing
all your staff together in one space
at the moment not at the moment no you
know i think we've got to get through
the next
few months before i'd feel comfortable
trying to get that many people together
that uncertainty is reflected by many
and there's much for individuals to
decide
mask wearing on transport perhaps the
most tricky
i think maybe once i've had my second
job
uh then maybe i'll stop wearing masks i
work in the industry where i don't see
many people now
just because they were in a basement so
i'll be happy we're not wearing it
yeah i won't be wearing knife if you
can't just put a date on something and
expect
people you know to say oh yeah well
covid is over
i mean it's with us we just we need to
learn how to manage but i don't think we
should be so ridiculous as to stop
wearing masks
the government also want to end bubble
restrictions in schools
whole classes sent homes wreaking havoc
but there are cautionary words from the
government's scientific advisors
another peak is still possible putting
the onus on people
problematic the strategy
is now clearer we will learn to live
with restrictions
we must now learn to live with the virus
the end
so longed for by all still controversial
to many
helen and smith news
very pleased to see the new health
secretary sergeant javid joins us on the
program mr javid
very good morning to you and of course
congratulations on your return to good
morning but
but what a job you have to do and i i
want to start if we can with perhaps
one of the measures which has caused a
little bit of debate
as announced by the prime minister
yesterday face masks
yes or no are face masks effective in
reducing transmission of covert 19.
well now if i can explain we need to
learn to live
with the virus and that is why yesterday
i set out how we plan to ease
restrictions from july the 19th
providing the tests that we've said are
met
and uh the reason we can afford uh to do
this which is to move from
a system of rules and regulations
including rules we currently have on
face masks
to a system of guidance and personal
responsibility
is because of the vaccine either vaccine
is is working it is uh our wall of
protection
your jab by jab brick by brick it is
provided
as with this protection which means that
although case numbers
are high as i said yesterday i expect
them to go far higher
what we are seeing is a severe weakening
of the link between
case numbers and hospitalization and
deaths and that is what is allowing us
to ease the restrictions
in this way so to turn to your question
about
face masks that's what is why we can
make this change
and and move to a system of guidance but
as you say
it has severely reduced the link between
infection and death but it hasn't broken
it
and it follows of course that if we are
going to see as you just put
it a very significant rise in infections
there will be a concomitant rise in
death so so again the question i did ask
was
are face masks effective at restricting
the transmission of covet 19 and if so
why are we stopping people wearing them
now
well we've in terms of coming to the
decisions that were announced yesterday
by myself and the prime minister
of course we've taken the best possible
uh public health advice scientific
advice we have the best advisors
in the world and and together looking at
the impact of the vaccine and the severe
weakening of that link
we of course are very comfortable with
the decisions
that were announced now i fully
understand why many people
will be anxious uh they'd want to be
cautious and that is why
other protections remain in place but
the vaccines
are working and if i can just quickly
just share an example of
why i'm saying that is that you're at
the moment here in the last 24 hours
we're getting case numbers around over
25 000
a day but when you look at
hospitalizations
and deaths your deaths for example are 1
30th of what they were the last time we
saw
case numbers of that type and and also
when we're thinking about our health
challenges and health problems
one of the things i tried to set out
yesterday as well is as health secretary
i'm also
very concerned about all the non-covered
health problems which
you know they haven't gone away and if
anything they've got a lot worse you
know the waiting list
has grown dramatically it's going to
grow a lot more before it comes back
down again
sadly there are many people that have
not come forward
with cancer problems with heart disease
problems with mental health problems
and i'm very concerned about that too
minister i i completely i completely
understand that i'm not going to ask the
question again whether or not face masks
are effective because we know that they
are
in the latest meta-analysis that came
out in the last 24 hours six million
individuals involved in it
shows that it reduces transmission by
the very least 25 percent
so i'm just wondering about the the
shift that we have seen between
last thursday and yesterday evening in
which you know we're not being told what
to do anymore we're being given
personal responsibility to to make our
own decisions so
on that basis in which circumstances
will you be wearing a mask
i always uh for the foreseeable future i
will be carrying a face mask with me i
think that's a very
responsible thing for anyone to do as
i've said the pandemic is
is not over and uh if i'm in a crowded
or in close space i will wear a face
mask
in fact i'll wear one if i was next to
someone or near someone that felt
uncomfortable with others not wearing
face masks that's the point and that's
what i mean by personal responsibility
yeah but but also we learned this
morning from the papers and in fact i've
stood it up myself i mean government
advisors have been briefing out this
morning that vulnerable people who may
well be concerned
about traveling on public transport
given that many people choose not to
wear a mask
you've given them the opportunity to do
so the advice from government for
vulnerable people people with maybe
suppressed immune systems and so on
is to travel outside peak times as we're
telling people who perhaps have received
a cancer diagnosis
that they will have to take a bus at
five o'clock in the morning that's what
this government means by personal
responsibility
well i i've given an example of when i
would wear a face mask and i hope other
people
would do similar but again to turn to
your particular question on face masks
why can we move from a system of rules
and regulation to guidance and personal
responsibility
it is because of the vaccine i mean the
vaccine is is working and
and the fact that now we've got the most
successful vaccine rollout
program in the world thanks to the nhs
and our scientists
you know what we have is a situation
where i think some four-fifths
of adults have had at least one jabs and
three
fifths have had two jabs and we've
announced recently our plans for a
booster program in september
and the purpose of these vaccines is so
that we can slowly
start taking our freedoms back your
people do want to see
a return to something that looks more
like normal of course there are still
other protections in place for example
the border controls
we're going to have a more proportionate
and balanced test and trace system
and so there are other things that will
continue
to protect us but the most important
thing is the vaccine and i would urge
everyone to make sure that they're
jabbed up
strangely enough i'm off for my second
job later on today so the advice is well
taken
but but just in terms of that thank you
i suspect i might need it getting up at
half past two tomorrow morning but just
in terms though of of where we go next i
mean
you yourself have conceded there will be
additional deaths increased infections
means increased death i'm wondering if
we can get a figure
what would be an acceptable excess
mortality rate from covid19 as we move
forward
it's it's i have to it's not about you
know something
some number and that's being acceptable
of course not you know what what we are
seeing is that with rising case numbers
and yesterday
i said we could see a doubling of case
numbers by the time we get to
july the 19th we are not seeing a
corresponding increase in
hospitalizations
and and death numbers and that is
because the vaccine's working that's
what the vaccine's
for and we can't live in a world where
the only thing that we're thinking about
is covid and not about all the other
health problems not about our economic
problems our educational challenges
and we have to make use of a vaccine
that is thankfully
uh working and and and be aware of all
the other health problems that i've just
mentioned a moment ago but as health
secretary
i tell you when i came into this
department with a fresh set of eyes
it is shocking when you look at all the
other health problems that have built up
some seven million people have not come
forward during the pandemic for help
from the nhs
with their health problems seven million
people now just think about
all the health problems that have been
stored up and and we need to treat that
as a priority too it cannot just be
about covid
sure indeed and uh as you mentioned the
the fresh pair of eyes that you bring to
it i mean
it has to be said your approach this
that which we heard from you yesterday
and the prime minister is is a country
mile away from from what we were hearing
from from the previous
health sector you have to consider it is
a different approach and that frankly
if matt hancock had remained in post we
probably wouldn't have had an
announcement of the type
we had yesterday so i'm just wondering
what has changed i mean the sage advice
has remained the same between thursday
and today the
you know the advice in terms of the the
data set has all been going in exactly
the same direction to my mind the only
thing that has changed
is that we all had to swallow a gallon
of mine bleach after we all got to see
the former health secretary grabbing his
aides backside i mean
where is the science that has led us to
making this
fairly fundamental change in approach
what's changed since
this pandemic is obviously we've learned
a lot more
about the virus itself and i've said a
lot about the vaccine but also it's
worth
mentioning the treatments are much much
better than they were at the start of
this year
one of my first visits i think on my
second day on the job was to saint
thomas's hospital
and and i went to the see the doctors
and the consultants in the wards where
they
were previously treating hundreds of
cobit patients
and uh and now they're at this the time
i went there are hardly any but what
they
also explained to me was the impact of
the drugs the treatment
uh that was now available as especially
dexmethazone
and that's important too so that's
something that's changed
since the pandemic but most of all
what's changed and again
i have to come back to the it is the
vaccines they are working and it is
allowing us
uh to take the measures that we
announced but let me say again
i absolutely can understand that many
people
uh will be will be cautious they'll be
anxious they'll be concerned
i absolutely i get that the prime
minister does my colleagues
throughout government do but we have to
take advantage
of the of the vaccines and the
protection they're providing how they
have severely weakened the link between
cases
and hospitalization and uh no one's uh
pretending here that
there's a the that this is all happened
before somewhere
and and and there's a risk-free way uh
out of this
uh we haven't pretended uh that uh the
uh the you know that in preach in past
pandemics here they've been very
different
um and so we have to learn as we're
going along but we're getting the very
best advice that there is available
in the world from the best scientists in
the world and together with their advice
we're moving ahead
do you understand why some people found
it curious to hear the prime minister
you know speaking from downing street
yesterday lecturing us all not to be
demob happy
on something that this government has
become very fond of describing as
freedom day
um i didn't quite get the question i'm
sorry you cut off
sorry i'll i'll repeat it do do you
understand why some people finally
curious that the prime minister told us
all yesterday
not to be d mob happy to go wild to
enjoy ourselves too much
on something the successive government
ministers have been happy to describe as
freedom day
no i i think that what the prime
minister is is reflecting there is that
still advising people uh to take notice
of the guidance and
and and to emphasize that we expect
and hope people will show personal
responsibility and i know people will if
you look at
the the huge efforts that the british
people have made during the course of
this pandemic
obviously not just following rules but
just you know taking a more common sense
approach to
social interaction uh for example you
know that is what
i think will continue and i think that's
what the prime minister is emphasizing
that's something that we'd all like to
see
just in terms of what might happen later
on in the year we heard of course from
chris whitty the prime minister and
yourself
i've all said that winter may be
difficult it may be difficult for the
health service
on that basis can we just be absolutely
crystal clear
the government retains the power to
reintroduce
restrictions later in the year if
necessary if
as i'm sure you would say absolutely
necessary
the one one concern that is uh still
there and this is
throughout the world is that there will
be new variants i think
no one can rule out there won't be
further variants of of covid and no one
will know
what they will look like there is a risk
and i think it's a real risk of
some kind of vaccine-resistant variant
there's no sign of that yet
anywhere but but i think it's something
that no one can rule out
and that is why it's sensible to retain
some powers and one of the things i said
yesterday for example that local
authorities
will retain their powers at least until
the end of september and before that
date we will
review them again so if there's a need
for the local use of powers
you know that that is something uh that
can be done uh promptly
and so it's it's important i think to to
remain
cautious in that way it's why we will
also retain
border controls uh your viewers will be
familiar with the
so-called sort of traffic light system
uh that will stay in place there may be
some proportion changes
to that i think the transport secretary
has already said uh that we can soon
afford to treat people that are double
vaccinated traveling
to amber countries differently but that
will also provide a degree of protection
and then also there'll be a more
proportioned and balanced test and trace
system so i think all of these uh taken
together
uh are there to continue to protect us
especially against the emergence
of a new variant but at all times we
will of course keep this under review
uh mr javit as i said before
congratulations uh on the return to
cabinet very big jobs to do
thanks very much for being with us thank
you
thank you for having me uh well let's
take a quick look at the
latest coronavirus data for the uk
uh there have been 27 334 new cases nine
more deaths were reported
which means the total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test
now stands at 128 321
while the latest vaccination figures
show another
77 222 received the first jab
111 410 received their second
in total 33.7 million have now received
both doses of a covered vaccine
restrictions on british travelers into
germany have now been reduced
meaning that people can enter the
country as long as they adhere to the
10-day quarantine upon arrival
this can however be shortened pending a
negative coronavirus test
at those people that are fully
vaccinated well they can avoid it all
together
uh meanwhile despite the new government
guidance we were just discussing with
the health secretary ryanair says
all passengers will still be required to
wear face coverings
although it's announced on monday that
masks are no longer a legal requirement
in most settings the airline has stated
they will still be mandatory on all of
their flights regardless of the
destinations
and as the vaccine rollout continues
here in the uk
the mayor of london surrey khan has
announced a new incentive to get
londoners
to go for their job you might be
wondering why we're looking at pictures
of england fans well here's the reason
50 pairs of tickets to watch the final
this sunday in the trafalgar square fan
zone
could be won by anyone that comes
forward to get their first doze
from wednesday one person and their
guest will also be invited to watch the
match
live at wembley yeah fingers crossed
uh here's how the morning's papers are
looking uh starting today with the
daily express it quotes the prime
minister it's now or never
uh but also pictures the teenager emma
radicani who's forced to withdraw
from wimbledon
three lions the headline in the sun
heralding the end of restrictions and
also of course looking
forward to tomorrow's semi-final
a different tone though from the metro
uh they say that boris rolls the dice
following yesterday's announcements
likewise the guardian
calls the upcoming changes a gamble
citing scientists concerned about the
changes on the 19th
and the mirror warns that the government
is masking
for trouble they quote a bereaved son
concerned
with the scrapping of mandatory mask
wearing
i have plenty coming up on the show this
morning
what is the labour party making of the
move to remove
the move to remove restrictions in
england the shadow health secretary
jonathan ashworth
will be joining me in the studio at
twenty five two
at twenty past eight jeremy hunts joins
us to discuss the health and social care
committee's new report
into maternity care services in england
you want to see that one
[Music]
and at water tonight i'm joined by the
former middlesbrough midfielder josh
walker
who played under gareth southgate and
we'll be discussing england's chances
tomorrow night
an immigration shake-up is on the cards
our reporter aisha zaheed joins us from
the newsroom actually good to see you
this morning
uh just take us through this pretty
patel has talked about this for quite
some time frankly
yeah they've been described as radical
changes as part of
home secretary pretty patel's plans to
fix
the uk's broken asylum system now
earlier this year we heard about the
idea of
offshore migrate migrant centers it's
not clear whether these will be
announced today
but we do know there will be harsher
penalties in place
for anyone entering the uk without
permission
knowingly they face up to four years
jail sentence and for people smugglers
they could face a life sentence as
opposed to a maximum of 14 years
and the home office have said they hope
these will help tackle
asylum shopping too essentially when the
uk is picked over other safe
countries but there are major concerns
with charities warning
thousands of migrants could be turned
away
and left without the help they need
aisha
many thanks indeed now more changes need
to take place in
england's maternity services in order to
keep babies safe
that's the warning in a new report
that's led the chairman of the health
and social care committee
jeremy hunt to warn that around a
thousand
more babies would live every year if we
copied sweden
uh skye's becky johnson has the detail
these babies should still be alive their
deaths the result of avoidable errors
with devastating consequences joshua
would be 12
by now pippa would have started school
and winter would be a toddler with a new
baby brother or sister on the way
her parents terrified of losing another
child
we got to the birth of our daughter and
it all went wrong and she
she was healthy there was no need for
her to have died
we've been left in labor for quite a
long time
we hadn't had the correct monitoring
that we should have
and winter was failed on numerous
occasions
and she died 23 minutes after being born
it's scary isn't it though
you know we know that we've got to face
those fears again
at a time when we should be enjoying a
pregnancy you know sarah says
i'll come and feel baby kicking but
you kind of don't want to get too
attached just in case
the trust that runs the queens medical
center in nottingham has apologized to
winter's family
and committed to improving maternity
services
but a report into maternity care across
england
says significant extra investment is
needed to tackle widespread staffing
shortages
and highlights a culture of blame when
things go wrong
that means mistakes aren't admitted and
lessons not learnt
i think questions really need to be
asked is um why
this has been allowed to happen for so
long richard stanton and his wife
rhiannon have been
fighting for lessons to be learnt since
their daughter kate died 12 years ago
the findings within the report if they
are taken forward if they are
implemented babies lives will be saved
mother's lives will be saved
there will be positive outcomes but
change would be too late for them
and the many families denied the chance
to see their children grow up
becky johnson sky news
time for a look at some of the day's
other news and around 150 students are
missing
after armed men raided a boarding school
in nigeria's kaduna state
the attack is the 10th mass school
kidnapping since december in the region
which authorities believe are motivated
by potential ransom
payments the police have stated that
they are in pursuit of those involved
in this most recent incident
cicelyn faye allen britain's first black
policewoman has died aged 83.
the announcement was made by the
national black police association
in a statement they said that ms allen
broke down barriers
and will have had a long lasting legacy
in the policing world
now the remains of four more victims
have been discovered following the
collapse of a residential building
in miami just under two weeks ago
apologies for the
lack of pictures there this brings the
total number known to have died to 28
117 people are still missing
to sports great britain's emma ratakanu
has been forced to retire from her
fourth round match against
alia tomianovic at wimbledon she was
experiencing breathing difficulties
uh radicand had been noticeably
struggling and after consulting with the
trainer and the doctor she took a
medical timeout
where it was deemed she could not
continue
uh she will be back though she will be
back now
the hollywood director richard donner
his credits include the original
superman film and of course the goonies
uh has died
aged 91.
[Music]
convinced the world that a man could fly
well that superman movie released in
1978
i saw donna face off with producers over
the need
for special effects that would convince
the audience that a superhero could
really fly
donner also cast christopher reeve who
was then associated with superman
but for the rest of his life and rightly
so the heads of marvel studios and
dc entertainment producers of most of
today's superhero fair
both worked for donner when they were
starting out
in hollywood but here is my favorite oh
this way
come on do it
who can forget that iconic scene from
the goonies released in 1985
the film which follows a group of
children hunting for a hidden treasure
has become a
cult classic watched by multiple
generations
and in reference uh to that particular
film uh uh
steven spielberg hailed dollar as the
greatest
goonie of them all um and in reference
well uh what we've just read that yeah
stephen
the actor mel gibson who found fame
starring in the donor directed lethal
weapon series described donner
as his friend and mentor saying he left
his ego at the door
and required that of others he was
magnanimous of heart and soul
which he liberally gave to all who knew
him if we piled up all the good deeds he
did he continued
it would stretch to some uncharted place
in the firmament i will sorely miss him
with all his mischievous wit
and wisdom
uh time now for the weather joe is
standing by and joe
it was it was tipping it down in the wii
u as i know because it woke me up
it was absolutely horrendous honestly so
much
rain around this morning dreadful
driving conditions
literally puddles everywhere surface
water a lot of spray coming off the
roads as well so do take care if you're
out and about
this area of low pressure is going to
pretty much stay with us till the
weekend not quite as bad but still with
us
let's take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
yes it certainly arrived with a splash
and it's still with us now
it's made its way in overnight the
heaviest rain currently over parts of
northern england parts of wales
parts of the midlands too so do take
care of your driving and through the
course of the day it will eventually
start to spiral away
in towards the north sea it'll be the
northeast that hangs on to the
very wet weather longest so for today
then
it is very blustery down to the south a
gust of 40
or 50 miles per hour along the southern
coast and probably the best of the
weather
is likely over the northwest of scotland
here we'll see some sunshine
and dry conditions during the course of
the day then that
wet weather continues to move its way
northeast was affecting northeastern
parts of england eastern parts of
scotland
elsewhere we'll see showers those
showers
as i say blustery down in the south some
sunshine in between
top temperatures around 20 21 degrees
celsius that's 70 degrees fahrenheit
but not really much of an improvement as
we go through the day
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
joe thanks very much indeed uh well
ahead of tomorrow night's
semi-final fixture against denmark uh
let's take a look
inside the england training camp
midfield was uh jack grealish and phil
foden alongside
uh left-back ben chilwell with their got
their preparations for the clash
well and truly underweight look they're
even doing kpis
if england can pull off a win tomorrow
they will of course earn a place
in a major tournament final for the
first time since
we had to mention it didn't we 1966
and i'll be watching uh you can also uh
you can uh
take us with you you can find us on the
mobile app or on our website you can
head into the live blog to watch the
program
and you can catch up on the interviews
on uh k barley's twitter i'll be
retweeting them from mine
as well uh no
in the last half an hour the health
secretary sajid javid told the program
he's very comfortable with the lifting
of restrictions in england
set out by the prime minister i did
however asking about whether he would be
wearing a face mask
after the 19th of july for the
foreseeable future i will be carrying a
face mask with me i think that's a very
responsible thing for anyone to do as
i've said the pandemic is
is not over and if i'm in a crowded or
in close space i will wear a face mask
in fact i'll wear one if i was next to
someone or near someone that felt
uncomfortable with others not wear face
masks and
and that's what i mean by personal
responsibility
uh let's speak now to the former
conservative health secretary
at stephen dahl of course formerly chair
of the nhs confederation chair of the
health committee as well someone
i'm sure with a few opinions on on what
we heard from the prime minister in the
health sector yesterday
good to see you mr doral and well let's
just start straight
straight straight forward with that uh
what did you make of what we heard from
the prime minister
is this fixing of the 19th of july is
the date for lifting all restrictions
entirely advisable in your view
well i think there are clearly risks
look i i think the worst
attitude to strike is to sound as though
somehow
uh we uh uh resisting or
uh reluctant to see lockdown uh removed
i think in a funny way the most
important
announcement the prime minister made
yesterday was one that's been barely
noticed
which was his acknowledgement that if
this pandemic
starts to take off and get out of
control again later this year
as the winter comes on these changes
may turn out not to be as he has
explicitly hoped irreversible i think
the important thing
is to continue to focus on the data and
not the dates to use his own phrase
and to ensure that we do respond quickly
if we find there are new variants
emerging or there are
a load the load building on the health
service starts to threaten
not just the health of kobit patients
but of all the other patients who rely
on the nhs
in fairness to the health secretary who
we had on the program just just a few
minutes ago and
a new health secretary at that i mean he
himself conceded that
if we see variants of concern emerging
later on in the year then we could
see localized restrictions take place i
suppose the question is when we are
seeing
such an increase in delta transmission
at the moment
fair enough there isn't the link to
hospitalizations and mortality
that we've seen in the past but when
we're seeing infections increase at such
a rate is this now the time to be giving
everyone the decision
as to whether or not to wear a face mask
i think the important thing here is for
the guidance to be
clear and the government's failed in the
past during this pandemic to give
clear advice uh the
wearing of a face mask in a confined
space for example in public transport or
also in shops actually
wearing the face mask is something that
protects your own health but it actually
more importantly protects the health of
the people around you
and so i certainly think that we should
continue to wear face masks in
confined spaces for the foreseeable
future because we know
that infection rates are rising and we
also know
importantly uh that when there are when
there's a rising
infection rate what's what's being
created
is what the public health people call a
potential variant factory in other words
it's facilitating it's making it easier
for the virus to mutate which is one of
the key risks
of the of the relaxation vlog
and even if no new variants were to
emerge which
which does rather stretch the
imagination a little but even if no new
variants were to emerge
we do find ourselves in a situation
where the chief chief medical officer
chief scientific
advisor the health secretary the prime
minister all concede that you know the
nhs
is going to be under huge pressure come
winter time
well we know it's it's always under
pressure in truth at winter time
we think it it overwhelmingly likely be
under additional pressure this coming
winter
because flu has been largely absent
because of the effect of lockdown so
there's likely to be
or there's certainly a a significant
risk
of a serious flu workload to the health
service
this winter and also if i may just pick
you up on your
it's stretching imagination for a new
variant actually i don't agree with that
i think it's overwhelmingly likely
that there will be new variants to this
virus before the pandemic is concluded
no no i i i perhaps didn't make myself
entirely clear i entirely agree with you
on that point there is the likelihood
that there will be
another variant but mr doral thank you
for correcting me rightly so
and thanks for joining us in the show
thank you very much
but let's now get the views of labour as
you can see the shadow health secretary
jonathan ashworth joins us once again in
the studio
good to see you mr ashworth um well
let's just be absolutely straightforward
do you agree with that which we heard
from the prime minister of the health
secretary yesterday
that you know barring some major major
events the 19th of july will be the
point at which
pretty much everything goes back to
normal i don't really agree
with that um approach excuse me i don't
really agree with their approach
look i want to see the economy reopened
in a balanced way
i want people to enjoy their freedoms
but we don't want a high risk
free for all remember the context which
we're in here
infection rates are increasing and will
continue to increase hospitalizations
are increasing
and in england around 50 of the
population
are double jabbed so what we're saying
to the government
is look yes let's reopen our economy
let's reopen our pubs our restaurants
properly
but let's be for caught let's be
cautious and let's put mitigating
precautions in place
let's make structures let's maintain
mass squaring on public transport
and in shops let's ensure buildings have
proper ventilation
supports and air filtration systems so
that the air is clean because we know
the virus is
airborne and let's give people decent
sick pay so they can isolate themselves
if you're low paid you still don't get
decent sick pay to isolate yourself if
you're ill
that is a massive massive failing so yes
let's reopen but let's put these
precautions in place what what what in
your mind because of course
one thing that was perhaps slightly
glossed over yesterday is we still need
to have all this confirmed on the 12th
of july as to what we'll have yes that's
true
a week after but but but assuming that
that does take place
what would could possibly happen between
now and the 19th of july
that would make you think you know what
perhaps this isn't the right time to be
to be unlocking well we've always got to
look at the data obviously
but remember what's happening at the
moment the virus is going up now boris
johnson said
we'll have 50 000 infections a day by
the july the 19th well
we had less than that when we grew our
own
kent variant the alpha variant and of
course we know we've got the delta
variant here because you'll recall that
we failed to protect our
that's our borders so there is a risk
that when you've got high levels of
virus circulating
that new variants emerge so we've got to
look at all these things
in the round but isn't that going to be
the case in in perpetuity
that it's you know the the the covert 19
will be around in some form from for
many many years to come there will
undoubtedly be
pockets of outbreaks that crop up there
will be variances we're discussing with
mr doro there
there will be variants of concern that
that emerge but the
the difference is at the moment is the
mortality has gone through the floor
yeah no but but we're also seeing that
people who are exposed to the virus
can develop very serious long-term
health conditions
which risk permanent illness or
permanent disability
as a consequence and of course we
haven't finished vaccinating yet only 50
percent of the english population
have had two jabs that we're going to
get much further on vaccination
we're nearly there but we're not quite
there yet i'm trying to dig down into
what what exactly would be the tipping
point then for labour to to be able to
support this
is it then that the the level of double
jab vaccination that there is in the
adult population i mean if it gets to 60
would that be enough for you 70 well i
think we've got to look at where we are
in the
trajectory because when bob johnson says
50 000 a day on july the 19th
he's not saying that is the peak he's
not saying it's going to start coming
down after that
i mean the likelihood is this will
continue to rise and rise and rise and
rise to a peak probably in about august
i suspect but we'll
we'll see and then start coming down
again so why not have more precautions
in place
if we know we're going up why not have
mask wearing in place why not do the
ventilation
until we know we're coming back down
again doesn't the prime minister though
have a point and there was one that
apparently chris witted well chris what
he did agree with him yesterday that
actually the summer months when children
are not in schools when the weather is
more
uh temperate you know when we don't have
respiratory illnesses
in the same way that we do in autumn and
winter in in such abundance
doesn't it provide us an opportunity
right now oh
there is a logic to this absolutely but
what i'm saying is let's just not just
throw everything to the wind
let's have some precautions in place but
also think about the implications of
what they're saying there
that suggests to me that they're
expecting the immunity to wane by the
autumn in the winter
and they're looking at restrictions
again in the winter perhaps another
lockdown in the winter
if that's what boris johnson is planning
he should actually be clear with us
they're being relatively clear in the
health sector this morning on the
program i asked him do you retain the
policy do you retain the power to
introduce restrictions
if necessary in the winter he said yes
localized but yes
well i mean two weeks ago or a week ago
when he was appointed he said this would
be irreversible
now already they're saying we're going
to have winter restrictions this winter
i missed that interview
i'll go back and look at it later but
they're basically saying we're unlocking
now
because we're going to have a winter
lock down that's basically confirmation
of what the government policy is now
do you see a a difference as a summers
and i made this point to the health
secretary but
but a big difference in approach between
you know a health secretary that was in
the job you know last wednesday thursday
and the health secretary that was in the
job on friday do you see
a difference in tone a difference in
emphasis between the two uh not really
not really to be frank because we still
haven't got sick pay sorted for the
for low paid people we've still not got
proper support for premises to ventilate
we're we're leaving it all up to
premises to put the ventilation in
themselves rather than giving them
uh support you know we've still not got
proper localized contact racing i mean i
suppose the difference is
uh social distancing is going but boris
johnson is replacing it with political
distancing because he's saying to the
individuals it's up to you
but it's not really because if i get on
the if i get on a bus
or a tube without my mask on i'm putting
others at
risk and that's the difference here you
know we should all continue mask wearing
because it's about keeping
all of us safe do not think people are
sensible enough to be able to come to
that conclusion on their own
well i i well i hope they are i hope
they are but i would have maintained the
mask mandate for now
if you hope they are if you think they
are then why can't they get away with
making a decision i mean boris johnson
said it himself i mean
i can't imagine the circumstances in
which mr johnson takes a train journey
late at night and you know in an empty
carriage these days
but you know he himself made the
distinction between being in a crowded
place and being somewhere where you know
there are precious few people around
i mean you've got to grant the british
public a a degree of intelligence and
empathy for their fellow human being
don't you well i mean
well well indeed that's an important
point but look yeah israel that we know
israel have got one of the
best vaccination programs in the world
they've now got the delta variant
they've reintroduced their mask mandate
because they know the delta variant if
you're double jabbed
you can still catch the delta variant
and transmit it
so they reintroduced the mass mandate
and i think let's just maintain that
precaution as we're going up this this
this third wave peak
to this peak just to just give it a
slightly personal question of course
you've been watching
opposite your matt hancock for for for
the
time in your post you know sanji javid
coming through what do you make of him
as a potential health secretary uh sachi
javi i don't know him very well to be
honest i mean
you know yeah i know he likes to boast
that he's been at harvard
studying pandemics well i think he
missed the tutorial on infectious
disease control i'd say that
well he's quite well actually to be sure
to get into mr gerald if you read his
uh you know his harvard missives he's
quite a strong supporter of face masks
well why is he not maintaining the
mandate i'll ask him about that later
today in the house commons i look
forward to it mr ashworth good to see
you this morning thanks being with us
and just a reminder that if you want to
catch up on any of the interview with mr
ashworth or mr javid or indeed simply
watch the programme when you're out and
about this morning
here's how you can do it you can find us
on the mobile app
you can head to our website you can even
go into the live blog to watch the
program
or you can switch on the telly how about
that you can catch up on the interviews
on
twitter as well
uh but for a bit of context to the two
big political interviews we've had this
morning our political correspondent
tamara cohen is here at tc what we're
learning
hi neil well dividing line here the
government has said
there's no need to wear masks anymore
it's the guidance still they're saying
that it's a courtesy to other people
when you're in a crowded space
and if airlines or transport networks
want to keep them
then they can but it's no longer
mandatory and inevitably lots of people
won't bother wearing them but they say
look it's now a matter of personal
responsibility and if people feel
vulnerable then they can
ask someone to put one on but they've no
longer got that protection of everyone
having to wear one sajid javid to be
fair did tell us that he would carry on
wearing one in some situations this is
what he said to us
oh well we don't have it but he said
that's worth he said wearing them in
some situations compared and contrast
them with others
labor saying uh we should keep that why
wouldn't we
open up in some ways yes get rid of
social distancing get rid of school
bubbles and we will be hearing more
about school bubbles
today a real problem for parents and
children 385 000 of them being off
school
but he says why not do all of that
but keep the masks keep a requirement
for ventilation in schools
and offices because the vaccine rollout
has only reached half of the population
so why not carry on with that for a bit
boris johnson's argument is if we don't
do it now
when can we do it because otherwise we
get into autumn the flu season and we
may not open up
until the end of the year and the
government scientists are behind him on
that
but they had a very strong note of
caution about the need to prevent
the spread of the virus because we're
already knocking on 30 000 cases a day
and it's only going to go up from there
so if there are new variants coming
um we know from some of the the papers
published yesterday
that it will make it harder to lock down
and we'll have to do it for longer
tomorrow thanks very much indeed uh
let's turn our attention
to afghanistan once again and after two
decades of conflict costing trillions of
pounds and
leading to thousands of deaths nato
forces
and are making a quiet exit the national
army in afghanistan will play a central
role in what's to come
it is now better equipped and trained
but the taliban remain
on the offensive threatening to return
to power our special correspondent alex
crawford
has been on the grounds meeting the
military forces taking on
the taliban
the afghan army is now all that stands
between every town
and the taliban the soldiers who've
relied so much on international
training air support and weaponry are
now being left to tackle the taliban
insurgency on their own every time that
they
leave their barracks they know that they
are the focus
of any attacks by the taliban because
the taliban want to show
that they're coming back into power and
it's only a matter of time before they
take over
the taliban's already moved into dozens
of districts across the country
and they're circling the capital
roadblocks are set up to try to secure
the perimeter
but the weapons on the streets indicate
just how insecure afghanis
are about their own safety
the uncertainty is palpable and there's
a great deal of tension
everywhere
the afghan soldiers fear they're now
fighting al-qaeda
and isis thought to already be embedded
within the taliban
and the scramble by international troops
to get out of afghanistan
appears to have empowered their enemies
who've had some rapid successes on the
ground
there's an awful lot of land that they
have got to try and get back
from the taliban and without those
international troops
they've got their work cut out for them
but the civilians
are growing more nervous with reports of
soldiers surrendering
and bases routed but every soldier we
spoke to
is putting up a brave front
the taliban tried to disrupt by laying
mines he told us
but we use our technical teams to find
them before they explode
but that confidence and the ability to
take on the taliban
isn't matched elsewhere
the rocky terrain of northern
afghanistan is home to the country's
most formidable fighting partnership
different fighters known as mujahideen
who joined forces
to form the northern alliance the relics
remain in the pangshi valley
of how they beat back superpowers like
the soviet union
and kept the taliban at bay
the son of the man who led them to those
victories is now stepping up to stop
this new
taliban takeover
we were given rare access as his convoy
of
suvs and armoured vehicles criss-crossed
the region
often at high speed
there's a feeling there's no time to
lose with the taliban trouncing areas in
the north
but the security force with him is
devoted to him
and his cause if talib will not
accept the peace we will fight with them
you're ready for this yeah absolutely
hundred percent massoud was only 12 when
his father was assassinated two days
before
9 11.
[Music]
the young man educated in london has
enormous support here
when he talks they listen and the crowds
in his home region are looking to him to
lead them in the new fight against
extremism
the young masood insists the national
army needs help
and without international troop support
the mujahideen are the only fighters who
can give it
he says there are thousands like these
men armed
and ready to beat back the taliban and
their extremist allies
they're gonna fight for democracies we
speak today they're gonna fight for the
rights of the people
they're gonna fight for the rights of
the uh woman
and they're gonna fight for many other
values that we cherished and we love
and we achieved in the past two three
decades so these are the things that
they're ready to defend
the preparations for battle come amid
predictions that the afghan government's
heading for a swift collapse
prompting a fresh migration crisis and
increased
isis attacks we are the first line of
defense we are defending europe we are
defending the region
and afghans are fighting not just for
themselves but for everyone
but former president karzai urged
afghans to all lay down their guns
and saved his strongest criticism for
america
the west must explain to us the presence
of daesh in afghanistan
it emerged during
the u.s prisons in afghanistan in the
name of fight against extremism and
terrorism
so they have failed america may dream
this is the end of its longest war but
those arming themselves now
ready for more battles fear it is far
from done
alex crawford sky news in northern
afghanistan
uh let's find out how the weather is
looking today joe's standing by at the
wall with the details
there's lots of blue on that map that
doesn't generally bode well joe
no it has to be said for july because it
is july isn't it
the weather's really not looking
terrific at all we've got an area of low
pressure which is going to keep things
unsettled until the weekend
and then we have another area of low
pressure so don't expect
to get the sun cream out anytime soon
let's take a look at the details
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well yes
this area of low pressure has moved in
overnight it's pushed
some very heavy rain northwards across
the country and if you do encounter that
wet weather this morning
do take care it's certainly going to be
unpleasant as a pedestrian
but it's not very good as a cyclist or a
motorist either
a lot of standing water and surface
spray and we've got strong winds as well
those winds strongest
along the south coast where there is a
warning out we could see gusts to around
40 or 50 miles per hour
so through the course of the day then
we're expecting this wet weather to
withdraw from parts of wales
make its way out of northern england
towards northeastern england and eastern
parts of scotland
it is fairly mild to start off with
although clearer skies in the far
northwest
uh meant quite a chilly start there but
it'll be northwestern scotland that sees
the best of the weather through the
course of the day
so the heavier rain makes its way up
towards the northeast and it leaves us
really with showers some sunshine in
between the showers and when you do get
some brightness temperatures up to
around 20 21 degrees celsius
70 degrees fahrenheit but don't get too
excited about it
we'll see more uh persistent cloud and
showery rain working its way in from the
west tonight and this untidy picture
stays with us into tomorrow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways